alors il est 20 un peu plus de 20h
est-ce que vous avez déjà quelques
informations qui vous permettent dans
votre canton mais éventuellement au-delà
du canton dans dans le département
d'avoir soit le sourire de la
satisfaction soit oui mais sur les les
tendances je pense sur le canton en tout
cas sur le département j'ai pas toutes
les tendances mais sur le canton ça
semble être conforme à ce qu'on a pour
l'instant comme première tendance au
niveau national donc avec un bloc UMP
assez assez haut assez positionné moi
c'est le cas sur le sur le canton et bon
on attend aussi sur le canton je suis un
peu pareil j'attends de savoir
effectivement 2ème tour si c'est PS ou
ou FN euh on verra bon comment ça se
comment ça se ça sort comment les
résultats émergent de tout ça bon et
puis le travail qu'il va falloir faire
effectivement de de rassemblement de
toute façon dès ce soir euh puisque il y
avait euh on avait plusieurs listes euh
même même à droite sur le canton donc
voilà il y a un vrai travail derrière et
puis B évidemment une satisfaction quand
même d'avoir vu que une partie de la
population on déjà fait confiance au
programme qu'on proposait pour le canton
et pour répondre au besoins de la
population vous pensez que dans ces
cantons où il y a eu
plusieurs représentants de la droite
officiels dissidents naturellement
l'électeur se reportera vers le celui
qui reste ben je le souhaite je souhaite
se reportera sur un projet qui est quand
même projet fait de conviction quand
même proche et donc il y a pas y a
normalement il y a pas de raison puisque
effectivement si on se retrouve face au
Parti socialiste on a évidemment pas du
tout les mêmes enjeux de de défense au
niveau du territoire et de même
engagement en matière d'emploi en
matière de défense d'activité locale et
je pense et je l'espère que les
électeurs évidemment se reporteront
naturellement sur notre liste vous
attendez à des duels contre le Front
national il y en aura certainement oui
il y aura certainement mais moi je sais
pas à l'heure où nous parlons je sais
effectivement pas quel sera l'état de la
situation sur le canton final il faut
attendre t les tous les résultats mais
il y en aura certainement est-ce que ce
vote départemental est
aussi attendez-vous un effet vote
sanction une politique beaucoup plus
globale il y a eu un vote sanction dans
les communes ça se voit puisque dans les
commune je dirais un peu plus importante
ou où la proximité joue peut-être un peu
moins on peut le ressentir on le ressent
moins dans certaines autres communes
donc bon c'est faut bien analyser
commune par commune he bassin de
population par bassin de population
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose moi
je sais qu'aussi sur le canton je vois
bien les les résultats que je peux avoir
commune par commune c'est aussi beaucoup
le travail avec Christine durant qu'on a
pu avec ma binum qu'on a pu mener sur le
terrain cette proximité que les gens
aussi on apparemment au moins apprécié
et au moins suivi dans un dans un
premier temps dans cette optique du
second tour euh donc c'est l'appel à se
rassembler à à faire front commun oui
c'est la nécessité euh pas à faire front
commun il y a pas un front commun il y a
c'est l'appel à se rassembler pour un
territoire avec Christine on a Christine
Duran on a évoqué la candidature telle
qu'on la voyait le rôle du conseiller
départemental de demain dans la
proximité et dans
l'efficacité vraiment ce qui m'a ce qui
est remarquable c'est l'attente de la
population d'efficacité d'élus proches
d'élus un peu qui qui sortent peut-être
un peu de de des engrenages habituels et
qui sont là vraiment pour rendre service
et pour être efficace pour la population